you've got a number of hurdles i think
now for boris johnson to get over um as
we speak one of the things that's going
on is it's largely the opposition mps ed
davy kierstama christian wakeford who
defected to the labour party from the
conservatives uh all calling for boris
johnson uh to resign that's going on
right now obviously you don't have
parliament sitting because we're in the
easter recess the first moment is
whether or not uh there's a moment of
jeopardy when parliament comes back so
could there be a vote of no confidence
two types of voters no confidence you
could get 54 conservative mps deciding
to write to graham brady to ask for a
vote of no confidence amongst tory mps
that could be one way
to trigger a contest that hasn't
happened so far we think it nearly
happened earlier in the spring but in
the end everyone decided to wait for
this moment
there could be a vote of no confidence
in parliament but frankly uh it doesn't
look as if conservative as if opposition
mps have the votes for that so even
though uh ed david calling for that i'm
not sure that's going to be particularly
uh a big moment the next decision for
boris johnson all around this period is
whether or not to announce that he's
appealing whether to accept the fine and
simply to pay it we of course don't know
whether it's one fine or multiple fines
meaning uh that it's
uh that it's um a a a big deal um but
then once you've got this process out of
the way the sort of police investigation
concluding and with 50 fines now we
don't know whether that's the end or not
then we move into a second phase of
investigation this is quite incredible
that this is all going to drag on for so
long for so long because at that point
once the police investigation is finally
formally finished then the senior
official sue gray kicks in and she
resumes the report that she's always
been planning to do she issued an even
an interim one a couple of months back
but now she's got to
prepare her full and final report uh
detailing as it were the story of what
when
what went wrong and perhaps
pointing a few of the political figures
that who was responsible uh who gave
permission for these events to take
place who should who should be
politically accountable for these things
and that too
could be tricky in itself that report
potentially massively painful but that
at the conclusion of that is the moment
that boris johnson
has
basically promised that he will finally
come to the house of commons and answer
any question about uh the fact that he'd
been uh that he'd been uh that he'd been
fined and what went on and that's when
he says he's going to be accountable so
i'm sure we'll see the prime minister
answer a couple of questions about this
in the next
24 hours or so but the big moment of
accountability that he's promising
is not presumably for some weeks yet so
this has got a long time to drag on and
just to have a look at some of the
conservative mps that are reacting in
private so they're not doing so uh by
giving their name but
uh i'm just messaging various tour mps
asking them what they think uh and
they're really they're not jumping to
conclusions one who has been critical of
the prime minister in the past saying
that they're not sure really they need
to see what their in books look it looks
like last time uh it was mainly labour
supporters labour voters having a pop
and just a few tourists we're not sure
uh whether people care anymore so you
get there a sense from uh tory mps who
have been crystal at boris johnson that
they're waiting to judge the public mood
before determining whether they for
instance put in a vote of no confidence
to borrow to graham brady chairman of
the 1922 which could uh trigger a vote
of no confidence
or whether they hold their council they
decide that now is not the time one of
the things of course that will affect
the way that uh conservative mps choose
to behave at this point is we are just
about three or so three or four weeks
away sarah jane from local elections
council elections all over the country
including uh wales and scotland uh in
which conservatives would hope to be
judged on their record but if this story
uh both uh the fines and perhaps even
what was going on last week with rishi
sunak comes to the fore and starts to
dominate then conservatives all around
the country are in fact
uh uh going to suffer and so that's one
of the reasons why tories might bite
their tongue perhaps some of them biting
their time simply until sugray's second
concluding report saying uh what she
thinks really went or on because one of
the problems that we're all going to
have at this point sarah jane is we're
not going to have very much information
does the prime minister get one fine
multiple fines does he choose to appeal
what was the event for which he's been
fined all of these things at the moment
completely unclear unless boris johnson
comes out thinking
that he needs to clarify those things
what's the story of behind what went on
who was to blame was this a surprise
birthday party for which perhaps the
prime minister's wife needs to take care
of the can or does boris johnson
maintain full responsibility those are
questions for sue gray so we've got
weeks of this to go
thank you and just a side note to boris
johnson potentially going to court to
fight this fpn of course if he's found
guilty in court he then faces the
prospect of a criminal record just a
note there on that intention that the
prime minister may have to take that
fixed penalty notice to court